we're on problem one
problem one
a project scheduled to be carried out
over a single fiscal year has a budget
of twelve thousand
six hundred dollars
divided into twelve
equal monthly allocations so if we
divide it by 12 how much are they going
to spend per month
so that's what one thousand and fifty
dollars per month right twelve thousand
divided by twelve is a thousand six
hundred divided by twelve is fifty so
they're going to spend 1050 per month
at the end of the fourth month of that
fiscal year the total amount actually
spent on the project was
4580. so 4580
after
four months
after four months by how much was a
project over its budget
let's see how much they should have
spent after four months so they spent
that much so after four months they
should have spent thousand fifty times
four
that's what that's
four thousand
four times fifty two hundred
that's how much they should have spent
after four months if they were on budget
they ended up spending four thousand
five hundred eighty so they spent let's
see how much they spent too much they
spent three hundred and eighty dollars
too much and that is choice a
next question
question two
for which of the following values of n
is
plus n
over n
not an integer
i don't know the
we could simplify this this is the same
thing as 100
over n
plus n over n which is equal to 100
over n plus one
so in order for this not to be an
integer and this is the same thing i
mean one is clearly an integer so this
can't be an integer right so we have to
pick an n that is essentially not
divisible into a hundred so what are
their choices
choice see they say one well hundred is
clearly divisible by one you'll get an
integer there so it's not one
two a hundred is clearly divisible by
two
100 divided by 2 is 50. so that's not it
100 divided by 3 that's 33.333 that's
not an integer so
choice
3 will not produce an integer if it's
selected for n so we're we're at c
answer is c
next question
three
rectangular fours x and y have equal
area
if 4x is 12 by 18 let me draw that
so this is floor x
and they say it's 12
by 18. this is 4x
and 4y is 9 feet wide
what is the length of 4y in feet okay i
didn't even have to draw this i think
oh what am i doing
undo
so floor y is
nine feet wide
so they're saying it has the same area
so essentially they're saying that nine
times and they want to know its length
let's call that l
so the area of floor y which is 9l
is equal to the area of 4x which is
equal to
18 times 12.
i don't even multiply this out because i
don't know off the top of my head what
18 times 12 is but we could just divide
both sides by 9 and we get l is equal to
let's divide the 18 by the 9. 2 times 12
which is equal to 24 and that's choice e
next problem
next problem problem four
a case contains c cartons
each carton contains b
boxes and each box contains
c
okay so c cartons okay case
is equal to c cartons
c cartons
carton
is equal to b
boxes
b boxes
and then they say
box
is equal to
paper clips
how many paper clips are contained in
two cases so we could say
two cases two cases
is equal to two c
cartons right
two c cartons
two c cartons are equal to
so each carton has how many boxes
has b boxes right
so this is going to be equal to
two
times
c right that's how many cartons and each
carton has b boxes so it's going to be
equal to two cb boxes
and then each of these boxes is going to
have a hundred paper clips so times 100
so that is equal to 200
cb
paper clips
200 cb paperclips and that is choice c
they wrote bc instead of c b but that's
the same thing
so that is choice c
next question
question five
the sum of prime numbers that are
greater than 60 but less than 70 is
so let's just think of them 60 is not
prime so that doesn't work 61 as far as
i can tell is prime
right i can't think of any numbers that
go into it although maybe i'm missing a
few 62 isn't prime that's even 63 that's
63 is
is 9 times 7 that's not prime 64 is 8
times 8 65 that's not prime divided by 5
66 nope
67 is 67 prime
is 67 prime
let's see 67 i think it is
i can't think of any numbers that go
into it 68 is not prime it's even 69 is
divisible by 3 and 70 is clearly not
prime so if i'm right that these are the
two
prime numbers let me make sure 61 is not
it's not divisible by 3
it's not divisible by 7. yeah 61 is not
divisible by
17 times 3 is 51 20 yeah the only
yeah
i can't think of anything that 16. so if
we add these two numbers up i get 128 so
choice b
i hope that's right
next
question question six
a rainstorm increased the amount of
water stored in state j reservoirs
from
124 billion gallons
to 138 billion gallons
if the storm increased the amount of
water in the reservoirs to 82 percent of
total capacity so this is 82
percent
of capacity
approximately how many billion gallons
of water were the reservoir short of
total capacity prior to the storm
so let's see
how many how many billions of prior to
the storm
so this is 82 percent of total capacity
so total capacity is going to be equal
to so capacity is going to be equal to
divided by 0.82 right
well maybe i skipped a step let me write
that 82 percent of total capacity is
equal to 138.
so you divide both sides by 82 percent
or 0.82 and you get capacity is equal to
over point 0.82
right
and then they want to know
how many
how many billions of gallons of water
were the reservoir short of total
capacity prior to the storm so it's
going to be this number this is total
capacity
minus what they were prior to the storm
124.
so we just have to do a little bit of
mathematics i don't know if they allow
to use this calculator but i think we
can do this on our own
0.82 goes into 138
and we could take this decimal point two
over so
we could make this
we could move this decimal point two to
the right
so we get that there so it becomes 82
goes into thirteen thousand eight
hundred how many times so 82 goes into
138 one time
82 we get six 13 minus eight is 56
560.
82 goes into 560.
well let's see 80 goes into
56 so it's going to have to be so it's
going to be 6 times
6 times 82
is 12
plus 1 6 times 8 is 48 49
and then we're left with
see what is that
this becomes a five well it becomes a 15
so we are left with
680 82 goes into 680
82 goes into 680 i don't know what is it
eight times
eight times two is sixteen
eight times eight is 64
65 and you're left with
i don't know what is this 24 240 so the
decimal keeps going but the total
capacity is about 168. so how short were
they 168 minus 124.
so 68 minus 24 is 44
gallons and that's choice e
let me give you a little bit of hairy
decimal problems i don't know if
calculators are allowed but
we did it without one
problem seven actually i'm almost out of
time i'll continue this in the next
video see you soon